I don't have an obsession with sex I've killed a lot of people until
now I don't think I'll get it while I'm still alive The
stench of a stranger is spreading The
shogunate pressured you to execute you You
said you wanted me to kill you, didn't you?
Let's make our wishes come true
Real It
is said that there will be a battle for immortality in the new election
Collecting interviews from all over the country
and sending them to the sisters
Wanting to have a strategy to acquit one's life Reflecting
the true nature of people The
temple Nogamaru  You're obsessed with sex
What do you know
?
It's me, it's me, it doesn't matter,
I'll
definitely come back alive
for you,
you said you wanted to see ninjutsu